each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available all right hi everybody um
welcome to uh Anita sarma's talk um I'm
Andy Bagel researcher in the vibe group
and Anita is a friend of mine who is uh
had a nice long history in software
engineering uh she did a PhD at UC
Irvine with Andrew vanderhook she's the
author of the famous paler conflict
avoidance tool which when I saw it I was
like damn it why did she invent that
before I did because that was a really
awesome idea um after she finished her
PhD uh dealing with coordination issues
for software developers she went off to
a postto at Carnegie melon worked with
Jim herbs lab um Mar catalo a bunch of
people there doing kind of neat things
in socio technical congruence about
trying to match up um software teams and
the work that they um that they do
together trying to keep that in sync and
um now she is a professor for the last
five years four years at University of
Nebraska in Lincoln
Nebraska um which is where my
father-in-law works so that's kind of
exciting too um and uh she is has been
working on a lot of things uh continuing
in Conflict avoidance uh for software
engineers and trying to help generally
software Engineers improve their
coordination and she's going to be
giving a talk today about distributed
software development and how to deal
with coordination there so I give you
Anita thank
you so that was a nice introduction
thank you so right now I'm at UNL and
our research group is called esquared
lab empirically based software quality
research so we don't just build tools we
try to make sure that the tools are
useful and that's one of the reasons why
I'm here we have had this amazing idea
built a new tool and then after talking
with Andy started realizing what is the
context in which it's actually going to
be used so one of the things I'm trying
to do here is talk to developers to kind
of see the kind of problems I'm trying
to solve exist and if not what kind of
problems they actually have just a
little brief uh introduction about what
I do um I have three strands of research
so first of them is empirically based to
understand what's really happening in
this communities that are actually doing
some kind of software development or any
programming related uh uh tasks so in
understanding online communities because
they are easy to get the information
from open source development or uh Q&A
uh programming based Q&A sites like
stack Overflow so one of the questions
in that area I'm interested in knowing
is what motivates them to contribute and
now we don't even have a single project
anymore like if you're doing your work
you realize you recogn you uh need some
other projects you need um people's
expertise from some other project maybe
so it's almost like an ecosystem there's
no monolithic project anymore like no
Island right you have an ecosystem
people have not yet looked into what
happens in ecosystem can I learn the
social nms and Technical Knowledge from
one project and transfer them to another
project so that's this little chunk of
my work is looking at these online
communities understanding how people
migrate from one project to another are
they transferable knowledge are the
specialized roles uh another part is end
user software engineering uh a lot of
you guys use
Excel and there's a whole bunch of
people out there who do some kind of
programming not because that's their job
but that's because they need to do that
to get their work done right so Excel
web mashups so over here I'm interested
in understanding what kind of software
principles and techniques we can
actually get from software development
and help this class of users uh looking
at how people do debugging in end user
software people just don't write quote
from scratch they pick some example from
one place put another example from
another place try to glue them together
and see if it works but when that
happens you don't know the kind of
examples that you picked and when you
put them together where's the problem in
the glue code in the first uh Pro uh
code you got and the second code you got
you have change it a little bit but you
know you don't know what's really
happening so can we help um these end
users debug and looking at how they even
go out look for examples how they are
trying to look for problems looking at
information foraging Theory to look at
the foraging Behavior the other Str the
one that I had started with in my uh PhD
project are still continuing which is is
how can we support coordination in teams
and uh while I'm in these strands one of
the things that I already talked about
we want to look at the state of practice
that's existing uh try to understand the
theories behind what's happening based
on those theories and insights build
tools and then evaluate them and that
kind of encompasses my research
directions today I'm going to talk about
mainly supporting coordination in
teams H all right so starting with
software development this is a little
nice piece of you know jigsa puzzle
that's out there and that's really what
software development is we have these
different pieces of code that we have
built by different people there's no
more one person building all the project
and all the code right we have to uh
divide labor will build things together
in and what usually happens is you know
this little uh spaces you have is almost
like Works spaces you take from the main
repository or whever the main archive
code is you take it out you work on it
once you are done you try to put it back
into the system
and hopefully all this interfaces line
up while you're making changes nobody
else has changed any of these other
interfaces right so you're hoping as I
work and I put things back in it will be
amazing piece of technology and it'll
work what happens in real life here is
the dependency packages in the pearl
language it's a pretty simple language
right and and the picture is from visual
complexity but if you see this picture
over here the blue stuff is package and
what you're really seeing is it's a
whole bunch of spaghetti code there's
calls from one pack package to another
package calls from a file in a package
to another file in another package what
that leads to is then social
dependencies among people because I'm
dependent on say Chris for his file I
get to have to coordinate with him find
out what he's changing if he's mucking
around with his code that might impact
me so if you look at the social
dependencies among these people this is
what you
get and to make matters worse these
dependencies are not static they are
changing over time because everybody is
evolving code so here is the same Pearl
language in this case you have the
vertical lines which means the
particular uh version or revision and
between revisions you can see how much
the code has changed right so some
versions don't have as much changes just
a little bit some have a lot of change
it might be because the new release or
it was an important part of the project
right so the take-home over here is
there are dependencies people depend on
each other and it's a moving Target
things continuously change it's been a
whole set of studies done to understand
how do developers work in this kind of
settings and more specifically looking
at what kind of questions to developers
have to ask some of them is like who do
I go to for help I just started on the
project I need to work on this work uh I
need to work on this piece of code who
has the expertise who can help me out
this especially too if you start a new
project right you have to understand
who's the expertise uh who should be
assigned to this task who has the right
expertise who can get this done in the
shortest amount of time sometimes bugs
get keeping getting reassigned because
you assign it to someone they don't have
the expertise then they assign it to
someone else so we call this hot potato
bugs they get getting tossed from one
person to another person uh which need
which tasks need to be completed before
the others there is dependency if I am
depending on some release or some um
code to be done before I can get my work
done I'm getting blocked on this other
person finishing their work right so how
do we in um manage or inter leave this
tasks uh other two questions is oops
which other artifacts are affected by my
change I here making pieces making
changes to my code who else might be
affected because of that on the other
side as I'm working I'm working on this
really important topic who else is
working in the space in my team that can
affect my work right so these are the
questions you have to ask because as I'm
working in my space I need to know
what's the impact of other people's work
and what's the impact of my work on
others so if you look at a bunch of the
questions is about the impact and
coordination can lead to or breakdown in
coordination can lead to two kinds of
conflict I say first is a direct
conflict which is I'm working on this
piece of code someone else works on the
same piece of code and when we ready to
synchronize we cannot do that in the
case of where we have configuration
Management Systems like subversion or G
usually what this translates to is a
merge conflict you have changed the file
Andy goes in first he's happy because he
gets to check in I go to check in second
and boom I have a merge conflict and
then I have to kind of see how to merge
them together it might be that they're
same file but the changes are in
different spaces so I can merge them
pretty easily but sometimes it could be
that there is some dependency that goes
from one block to the other block so
what happens then I I stick it in uh we
don't build or we run test and then
something still doesn't work or another
case where I things look fine I built
fine everything is fine I my unit does
go fine I stick it into the
configuration management system because
all the files are fine but then
something fails build or test and that
might be because something else
dependent on in Pi or some Behavior got
changed on the side and when we actually
ran the bill test that's when things
failed so these are undesirable
consequences and literature studies uh
in different kinds of projects some
pretty large uh communication um
projects somewhere Telecom project
somewhere at Nasa somewhere smaller
projects a lot of studies has been done
that shows this is a problem that keeps
happening uh work is frequently
restructured because what you would want
is all the little pieces P to work but
this little pieces should be given to
separate teams with good apis but as you
keep working things get changed right so
you have to restructure work to bring
back the
modularity parallel work does tend to
lower the quality of the code and that's
because you'll have merge conflict and
sometimes when even you automat
automatically merge it there might still
be some
problems developers recognize the
significance of conflicts nobody would
like to do conflict resolution even if
it is merg merges are hard because going
back to the old cases of SVN when you
actually do an update and merge you got
a lot of squiggly lines me them me them
you have to go through all of them and
try to fix it right so people have seen
that people try to race so they would
say this is very old work like from 95
from Becky grinter and what she saw was
people used the CM system logs as almost
like coordination time like okay uh Tom
checked it out one day back the release
is coming up in one week so he would be
you know at this stage so I better hurry
up because I want to check in first I
don't want to resolution people also
sometimes use another practice called
partial commits so even though my thing
is not completely done it's not tested
yet I want to put part of my code in
because at least then that part of the
code would be saved from me having to do
resolution right and these kind of
informal practices kind of go against
the basic software engineering
principles we have that you should have
tested code that goes into the
system uh another thing is informal
Communications take place this was from
a study um in Aerospace company and what
they did they had really long check-in
cycles that is almost 2 weeks long so
people would check out and keep working
on their code in 2 weeks time they'll be
ready to finish and put it back in the
system that is a long time when things
can change so what they would do they
send an email out hey I'm ready to check
this piece of code this piece of code
has dependencies on these other
artifacts is there someone out there who
will be affected you know speak now or
forever hold your piece kind of stuff
and then they'll have this all this
email communication back and forth
outside of the CM system once they knew
what what was happening who's going to
be affected and how changes will
actually be integrated then they will go
ahead and uh put it in the system and
this is something I found uh when we
were doing it in a class project with my
tool workspace awareness we were like
nobody had any conflicts it was amazing
all these four people uh project nobody
had a conflict and then I got the email
logs and there was a whole bunch of
actual informal communication and
coordination going on outside of the
configuration management
system and they only had in this case
the student had only one person who
could check it in so he was the manager
he would get all the code make sure
everything worked fine before checking
it in uh resolution is timec consuming
uh recent study by bronal and U my work
has shown in open source project that
resolution time takes hours to days to
take
place one thing I have an intuition
about and has been a little bit talked
about in literature is everybody knows
about this merge conflicts and you know
that that is a coordination problem but
many people recognize that IND conflicts
like test failures or build failures are
also actually caused by coordination
problems this think that's a regular day
life you have nightly bills and you have
all this processes set up to overcome
this problem nobody thinks that if he
could actually coordinate better if he
can understand these dependencies maybe
this whole class of problems would not
be even here that's what I want to poke
more in uh in my study which we looked
at four projects that was also the four
projects that yui Brun and his
colleagues had looked at so we wanted to
see okay do conflicts occur how big is a
problem right this before I go over
trying to solve this so if you look at
this projects we have this was all these
projects were in git so we looked at the
number of merges there were and the way
we looked at the git tree structure was
if there was a merge that is two
branches actually merged together we
would run uh if it was a safe merge
clean merge then we would run a build
script and these projects had the build
and test scripts if the build passed
then we would run test on them so we
maybe we make sure at the range how good
the quality of the codee was and when we
look at this you see the total number of
conflicts range from 40% to 54% that's
quite a few number of merges that had
some sort of problem right uh further
looking at breaking these conflict to
merge build or test we see that um it it
ranges very differently for different
projects you have some had 14% Pearl had
only 18% then we also wanted to look at
the time it takes to resolve these
problems and this was surprising to me
because I thought merges would be the
easiest to solve in the case of PE it
took an average 23 days and a median of
10 days to resolve this merge conflict
caveat these are open source project it
does not mean when there was a problem
that they actually eventually went and
uh you know resolve it then and there
this is how long the uh merge or the
problem existed uh going through it
seems like Bill failures is the easiest
for Pearl to manage test and merges are
difficult uh and different projects show
different profiles but uh take away home
uh home message is you have merge
conflicts between 8 to 19% of all the
merges would have problems build of the
clean merges range from 2 to 15% if you
look at the test conflict up to 35% so
there's a lot of problems out there so
uh I merge and build conflicts and test
conflicts are common among teams where
multiple people are working together and
increasingly there's lots of uh pieces
of software that are individual
developers are small or something like
apps for instance how do you see
certainly there are soot technical
issues there but they're entirely
different than these type of conflicts I
think so what how do you see sort of in
general like software development do you
see these types of conflicts
growing it it depends on the process
right so if you're doing agile it's less
time that people have to make changes
but if you are talking about that
individual pieces are being developed by
individual people like in a branch no I
don't even mean that I mean some uh
16-year-old is developing a game for iOS
and he doesn't have he's the only person
on the project right so he doesn't have
these type of
conflicts so then these exactly merge
conflict and build failures would not
exist what he would have problems is
when he tries to have the game work on a
particular operating system that's when
things would change so this is really if
he had worked off from version one and
now he version two forward compatibility
versus backward compatibility and then
he'll have to fix it so I think if if
this is based based on a team setting
these kind of problems if it is
individual problems it is the dependency
that you have with one API multiple apis
and keeping up to date about which API
you have built on and how far it has
moved so that's where I think it'll go
so I guess I'm I'm asking you to
speculate about uh the API um API
conflicts versus this type of conflicts
in the future what are we going to see
more
I think these kind of projects still
going to stay um if you have
individual project individual people
building stuff I think the apis will not
be as big a problem because they should
be Backward Compatible in the apis and
they are slower moving than the semi
structured apis with within a team
so yes they will stay but it'll be not
as bad as these and the way you'll
resolve it will be different because you
really do not have any control over what
this other API is moving towards and
where it's going because you are kind of
a consumer you are a client for that API
so unlike until you have like a Facebook
kind of application which is very big
you probably will not be able to have an
impact on the API development or the how
fast they moving okay sir all
right so as part of my work what I want
to do is is as I said there's the reason
these problems occur is because there's
some kind of dependencies and I want to
say Can individuals be able to visualize
what these dependencies are understand
who is interdependent on their own work
and then can we help them coordinate the
tasks so first I'll start with
visualizing the software dependencies so
built a tool called TCT which
is a
multifaceted way of exploring your own
project what is it does it has an
environment that correlates and
understand relationships across these
different entities in any particular
software development you have this
different silos in which your data uh
exists you have the code versioning
system where all your code exists the
bug versioning system with the issues
and uh bugs are there then you have
email communication that's going on the
side but anytime you want to look into
this data you have to go into one
database look into it then look at the
other other part and try to decipher the
links or relationships between them so
what this tool tries to do is kind of
says can we um explicitly State how
these relationships are and how they are
over time so the Tool uh this is in open
source data Rhythm box and gome so what
this does it has four panes on the top
pan you can choose a particular project
and for that project it then shows the
activity level of that project on the
top part over here you see the blue
lines and those are the code commits
that happened over the course of time
and on the bottom is the green lines
which is communication how much
communication happened and in this case
in gome we had the email exchange from
the mailing list we had any kind of
comments that were taking place in the
bug database bug track and bugzilla and
anytime there were any patches so we're
assuming that if I submitted a patch to
Andy Andy looked at it he probably knows
what I was trying to communicate and if
Chris uh comments on that particular bug
he probably let read what I had written
so that kind of shows a communication in
this case all three of us are
communicating with each other on the
left pane it shows the file Network
graph and it shows how files are
connected with each other since this is
open source data what we used is if two
files had been committed together we
call it logical commit or co-c committed
there must be some kind of logical
dependencies between these files because
of which they were committed together on
the right hand side here we show The
Social Network or the uh people Network
who's communicating with whom and the
bottom part is the bug database so or
the number of bugs that were uh open for
this period of time that we have have if
I look into more into this uh email
communication or the communication
Network what we have trying to
understand is congruence and congruence
really means if what's the fit between
the people who had to communicate and
who are actually communicating right so
in this case if Chris Gina Andy are
working on some project together there
is some dependencies right so what we
are saying if they have checked in some
files together there is dependency
between the files there's dependency
between these people so we say there
there is a need to speak and if you look
at the green um Network here so that's
the gray one here the green Network says
these are the people who are actually
communicating with each other then we do
a map between these two networks to see
if they had a need for communicating and
that's green if they had a need to
communicate but they were not
communicating that's red and there is
this gray line which means we didn't see
any technical need for them to
communicate but they are still
communicating for some reason right so
we call this the congruence and the
thickness of the line shows how many
times they had communicated with each
other it's just Edge weight so going
back to the picture so I had that uh big
cluster of files and it says that's too
many for me to understand so let me
filter it out so over here I have
filtered out that only show me edges
that have been committed five or more
times then I get this network and I see
okay this particular node over here
shell uh. C is kind of Central so I want
to
know who has been who has been working
on that so if I click on it in this uh
um communication Network it highlights
the people who had ever worked on this
file and then I can see oh these people
are actually communicating with each
other so maybe whatever changes had been
done they actually knew about what are
the significance of the edge lengths in
the file graph uh this is just a force
directed layout so if it your father it
just tries to put them away so if they
have been connected um multiple times
they'll be closer it's just a layout
picture so if they are farther away it's
just trying to like keep the graphs as
far as possible so in here you have them
closer because there are multiple
connections going
on all right so other thing I could be
interested in knowing is all right here
is my bug list if I click on a
particular bug this tool tells me okay
the two people who had worked on as part
of this bug are these two people and for
this particular bug these files had been
changed so what tect does is it allows
you to go from one perspective of your
project say my uh bug reports to kind of
my developer history to kind of my
project history so it allows you to
explore how things are connected and
give you more idea of what the
relationships are and what they might
mean when we looked at
um user studies as well as just
interviewing with gnome developers what
we found especially for gome was people
who were seasoned developers who had
been doing this project for like five or
six years they said I know this network
I am perfectly aware of which files
changed for with what I know who is
working on what then then we asked like
so how do you know that and this
particular person would spend morning
every day at least three to four hours
going through the entire mailing list
kind of seeing what's the status of the
project he was that into the project
right but he did say like it'll be
dearly useful for onboarding or finding
experts uh expertise finding for people
who do not care about the project that
much so his was like if you really care
about this project if you're an open
source person you should know this you
should have this mental model in your
head if you're not that serious or if
you're new this project would be this
tool would be really
helpful a couple of them were managers
and the thing that they picked on was
like I love when I see a red line right
because I know these two people should
talk but they are not talking so I
should be able to facilitate them
another thing that came out was what we
have in this data is only things that
are archived so even if I'm not talking
with someone over email and uh maybe
over a bug bug tracker it might be I'm
sitting right next to the person and I
talk to them all the time so one of the
to Features they wanted to say was like
yes is a red line but I want to click it
into green because I know I've have
communicated with that person or as a
manager I know these two people talk to
each other during the
meeting another thing was interesting
was we had brokers in the communication
network not in this picture but we would
see that um A and B had a red line
between them but there was this other
person C that they communicated with
right so it would say like you know even
though they're not talking directly to
each other there is a manager there's
some facilitator through which
information is passing from one note to
another note of of course the success of
this project depends really on the
existence of Link often times you don't
find that in open source data at list so
if you have the commits that have
happened the files that have changed how
do you link that to the bugs or uh how
do you link that to any of the patches
that have happened so that depends on
the link and Chris word over here had
this tool that was allowed to actually
decipher the links or add links to
commit and the uh bug so that'll be
really useful in a tool like
this so going on to the next set of uh
tools or two tools I'll talk about is
basically how to have coordination in
helping with distributor
development
so as I said earlier we have this
complicated interrelated piece of code
that we need to work on we all work on
in our own private workspaces so the
idea of workspace awareness was can we
monitor this private workspaces as
people are um going about their daily
everyday life can we know what files
they they're changing what's the
dependencies that they're changing to
identify this potential conflicts which
will be the merge conflicts and the
built conflicts that we talked about
which comes from dependency violations
and can we notify developers about this
as as things are happening as people are
still making changes so instead of
waiting till they have made their
changes and committing it can we move
forward in time and say as you're making
changes hey this might be a problem and
you want to talk to them and that was
the pentri tool which was my PhD project
that Andy was talking about so what we
did was we wanted to make it really
lightweight because the more stuff you
have in your development editor it
distracts you it interrupts you so what
we tried to do was we just uh took over
the package Explorer view in uh eclipse
and we this really small little icons
right so if you look at the Blue Bar
blue icon over here what we said was you
are working on this particular file and
someone else right now is also working
on this particular file so so there was
an option where you could have this on
for all the files you had in a workspace
or you could have this view only for the
files that you're dirty that means you
have changed it since you have checked
out and what we did was just saying
someone else is doing it we also wanted
to say what is the civility how big is
the change that you'll have to deal with
and we did as the percentage of lines of
code that have changed over the entire
lines of code for the file and the other
was we want to show them how this
information could be percolated up the
directly structure because it's often
possible in a large project you have
multiple projects or packages that is uh
collapsed so you wanted to say even
while you're on the top view if anything
in any of the underlying packages or
directories had changed and for that
what we did was a very simple directory
civility calculation which we said um
how many artifacts does this package or
project have out of that how many have
been touched by somebody else and just
aggregate that and put that in the
directory and we keep going that upwards
right so if your directory had two uh
files one was changed so the the
percentage change for the directory will
be 50% if that belong to another
directory which was two other
directories it will become 25% right so
it just keeps going up and getting deks
a little
bit the other thing which we wanted to
do was uh merge conflicts are still
easier to identify can we in some case
find these build failures or these other
indirect conflicts that are more
difficult to find so here we have this
red little icons and we wanted to say is
What's Happening Here There is the uh
changes in address with whatever is the
amount of severity there but changes
over that is causing some kind of impact
uh into your system so that's what the I
for impact leading out and here you're
working on credit card because you have
this um little arrow here which shows
you're working on credit card and the
impact is coming to yours so what we did
was we did cross workspace impact
analysis it was very simple analysis
very um rough analysis at this point so
for each workspace we made a lookup
table saying from call graph which other
files and which other methods you're
dependent on this particular file and if
in a remote workspace if some method or
some file was changed we would get that
notification we'll just do a simple
lookup if you're using this method this
method has been changed we say there
might be an impact and this is right now
at the signature level so if anything
actual behavioral changes we would not
have found out if anything the signature
changed we would have found
out and we gave more information uh on
this little View and this was my
attempts at drawing bombs uh so a red
Bomb would mean that someone has changed
a method that we're depending on uh in
this case someone has deleted this
particular method get name um is
impacted by Len on Pete's work and it
says the red means that changes have
been committed so this is definitely
going to be a problem a yellow bomb
meant something is happening in the
workspace so this might be a problem but
we don't know they might revert this
change back and then green was if you
have changed anything in your in your
own code and uh you wanted to find out
what else impact will impact in your
particular project but another
interesting thing was this exclamation
point as I said what we had done was a
very simple callgraph signature level uh
analysis at this point but what we
wanted to say was hey uh in this
particular uh resource you were
depending on payment um you depending on
payment your credit card was payment and
something has been added something new
for example init method has been added
so the system was not smart enough to
know like you depending on payment a a
lot of the initialization code had been
moved to these other methods so the
behavior had changed we said that's a
lot of complicated analysis the user
usually has a lot better understanding
of the domain knowledge it has a lot
better understanding of what the systems
are what people are doing so we wanted
to say by exclamation point like a new
method has been added what's the details
of this new method so as a user if I
know payment initialization is important
to me I will go and check what's
happened or talk to Ellen to see what
she's doing so we try to um offload some
of the more complicated computation part
to the developers because they would
know better idea
so when we looked at the results we saw
conflicts were pretty good being
detected as they emerg as long as they
were the syntactic level we found
developers undertake action upon
noticing a potential conflict and in our
user study we found a whole spectrum of
people right so some PE uh people were
as soon as a little bit of conflict
information got in they had to go look
what it was and there was one particular
uh user who could not have anything that
is you know conflicting so they had to
go and like find out what it was start
an email communication or IM
communication to see why it was and then
the other other Spectrum were people who
would just open the editor really wide
and they would not care about what's
happening in the package Explorer viw so
all that details were lost so only time
that these people group of people would
look at the package Explorer view or
look at the conflict was when they were
starting a new task or when they were
looking at another file because a
particular task might have multiple
files so that to go open the package
Explorer view or when they were taking
breaks one of the tasks in the user
study was they had to write comments
people always wrot comments after the
fact so they would code everything up
and then they would open the package
explor view take a break look around
then write comments look around write
comments right they didn't like writing
comments at least the students we had so
those were the times where people looked
at uh the conflict icons uh fewer
conflicts grew out of hand um this was I
I don't have uh details about the
experiment setting but this was using a
Confederate study so we had one person
come in and we told them they're working
a group the other two people could only
be contacted through IM uh but these
were our uh Confederate so they our uh
research uh helpers and we had like
every 15 minutes into a particular task
that would be conflicting we would see
the conflict and it was automatically
checked in so we saw some people trying
to raise they would have this blue icon
com in and said oh I need to go fix it
before this other person actually checks
it in so they tried doing that racing to
finish it then they realized it's
already committed so they were really um
once they F faced a conflict and they
had to resolve it they were really
particular in making sure this other
group of people uh who wanted to have no
conflicts as soon as an icon came come
came in they would contact this person
and say hey I'm working on this task
these are the files I'm changing what
are you working on how how much time
will you take to work on so they were
trying to synchronize and manage uh
through the
IM um so the resulting code was higher
quality uh in the terms that fewer
conflicts were left in the code base and
and this was based on because we had
seed four conflicts in an eight task uh
experiment there was a penalty because a
lot of people were communicating over I
am and it takes time to communicate so
the control group people uh were faster
than the experimental group but they had
more conflicts left in the code base uh
once we said okay now experiment is done
here is um all the conflicts or
dependency problems there could have
been one of the faults in the experiment
was which I didn't realize at that point
we did not make the control group
resolve all the build failures they
should have taken time we didn't do that
anyway so that was fun and there are a
lot of other workspace awareness tools
that have come after paler done better
jobs in UI and better jobs in the kind
of uh analysis is being done uh this is
fast Dash which was from Microsoft so
Mary's group and what they did was like
here are all the files and all the
people that are being worked on this in
agile setting so they would say which
particular file
what's the status of the file if a file
is being worked on by two people they
show the names of the people there and
like this is a problem space you might
want to look into that uh this was by
Yuri uh and his group and what this is
done this is based on git and they look
at there is um G works in all kinds of
branches right everybody has their own
branch and sometimes people uh do local
commits smaller commits before they
actually uh push the changes back into
the master repository so they had a
shadow repository they pulled in all the
local commits into the repository and
they would be be able to say like you
know when there is a possibility that
there would be a problem a build failure
or test failure by actually running the
build and test scripts on this master
Shadow
Branch all right so few of the
limitations of palent here and this
other workspace awareness tools or the
way the approach works is conflicts are
only identified after they occur right
so as I'm making changes as I'm doing
stuff these monitoring spaces tell me
here is a file that is going to have a
merge conflict or here's a dependency
that has been violated and the more
changes that have happened the more time
will take to
resolve they are usually doing course
gain impact uh analysis at this point
because of this notifications coming in
there is the case of information
overload and Interruption that we saw
from the palent
study and the opportunities for
improving or extending these kind of
analysis to a larger unit like tasks or
like scenarios and features that
Microsoft uses the problem is because
all the analysis is done at the file or
the directory level so bringing it up to
a higher level like logical units like
tasks is kind of difficult from the
setting so what I wanted to do next was
can we go even more um forward in time
can we be proactive can we find these
dependency problems or find when changes
are going to have any issues before
people have even started doing their
changes can we look at the tasks that
they are going to work and figure out
the dependencies at that point so then
we can also give them the Solutions at
the task level and one of the things I
wanted to look at was would this avoid
individualistic Solutions right so in
pantry when we had these blue icons or
these red icons people want to go race
in or do partial commits or talk to the
other person and say like I want to put
my code in right so it was a lot of
individualistic setting can we look at
it so that uh avoid the race conditions
or and this kind of individual
strategies to see what is good for the
entire team maybe it is okay for Chris
and Andy to have some conflicts here
because they are working on a code that
doesn't need to go for this release but
maybe Gina and Tom should not be
affected right so there might be based
on the team policies a different
strategies that this could
work so we built Cassandra so paler was
the Crystal Ball from Lord of the Rings
so you'll know what's happening in the
Seven Kingdoms so you want to say can we
go to cassander right is can we predict
even before tasks uh have been started
on what are the future problems that
could occur right so that's the Greek
mythology Cassandra so we can minimize
the conflicts that can arise from the
individuals working in their
workspaces so this is the approach for
Cassandra so first we assuming a
workflow where this is more uh akin to
the workflow that might happen in open
source so I come in the morning I say
okay these are the bugs that I have in
my inbox by pulling it from bugzilla or
something I might want to order the task
based on my preferences or any kind of
priority that we have after that we what
we needs to be done is kind of identify
ify the files that's going to be changed
for the particular task and once we have
the files that's going to be changed
what are the dependent files of what's
the files that can be
impacted and then we have to analyze
this task to understand the dependencies
so that we can understand the conflicts
and then we formalize those constraints
into hard constraints or soft
constraints which I'll talk about in a
few minutes and then we evaluate them to
find which tasks can be independently uh
created and we use Microsoft Z3 actually
to do the constraint evaluation here so
give me let's me give you an example of
a constraint example so here we have say
shape. Java we have three other classes
that are inheriting from shape if we
have a scenario where we have Alice who
has three tasks ta1 A2 A3 Bob with tb1
B2 and B3 in task one Alice is working
on rectangle and shape and task uh in uh
B1 Bob is working rectangle and
square if you look at the uh example of
the dependence right so if Alice and Bob
were to do their first task they going
to be one merge conflict because they're
working on the same uh class here
rectangle they're modifying it there
might also be indirect conflict because
uh whatever changes Alys might be making
to shape might affect square or triangle
that Bob needs to work on and there
might be some order like of trust
precedence like canvas needs to be built
before panel can be uh inherited from
canvas and being built right so there is
some uh precedence ordering that is also
necessary in tasks so what we do that we
convert that into hard constraints that
is ta2 has to be done before A3 there's
no other way around and then the rest
are soft constraints so ta1 and tb1 can
be done in parallel but there will be
some consequences with
that so looking at how do we get the
constraints from uh the Fe and the FD
set so what we are using is either we
could use um some kind of data mining if
it's a bug uh feature or bug request
that needs to be done we can look back
in time time to find out what other bugs
are similar what other files might have
been changed for that bug right so we
have a seat set of files that will be
changed for that particular bug and the
user can definitely refine it by adding
more files or removing more files uh
going back to like how milin does its
context so usually you'll have a task
you can say I'm going to change these
files I'm going to look into this files
so we can have some developer input for
refining and then we can do a basic
analysis like again going back to
dependency finder it's looking at the
call graph analysis one hop level to
kind of say these files are also
dependent on these other set of files
then you have this Fe and the FD set so
if there are two people and their Fe
sets are intersecting that means there
is going to be a merge conflict right so
there is going to be a direct uh
constraint between these two tasks if
you have an Fe set and it might have
some impact on this FD set which
somebody else might be working on right
so then there will be an impact so we
call this indirect constraints so right
now we are only looking at Fe sets
impact and FD set which is being changed
by someone else it could be that there
are two different sets and the impact is
somewhere down Downstream in another set
of files and that needs a little more uh
refined
analysis so once we have these
constraints we need to evaluate them and
we're using Microsoft Z3 so we have
these constraints between all these
tasks we put it into Microsoft Z3 and if
there's a solution that is there exists
for these two people two tasks that did
not constrain each other right then what
we want to do there is solution but we
want to try to match it as close as to
the developers preference or the
developers priority so to do that we
look at okay this is a solution that Z3
gave to us 42 3 1 is an order which
won't have any problem but the developer
wanted to do 1 2 3 4 so it's kind of
very far from the preferences so what we
want to do is minimize the cost so if it
is we find out how far so four was three
hops away so we say okay there three
units is the cost at this at this point
so you try to say okay for this solution
how far is it from the developer's
preference and we make a cost object out
of that and then we put that cost back
as a constraint and say in this case
there is a three uh two so there's a at
least five places that would be changed
right so we want say we want to put that
back in the constraint solver and say
try to minimize this cost from say 5 to
three so we kind of go binary and see if
there's any solution so we go back and
try to revaluate the constraint space
and we keep doing that until we find the
cheapest uh cost function that we have
because that's the minimal set we could
get and then we want to display this
information um back to the user I said
this is your recommended
task to do that the UI what we have is
this is myin and over here is the milin
uh task view we kind of hijack that task
view task list and say okay if these
were the tasks that existed uh for this
particular uh person and one two three
was the ordering that they were going to
do uh myin uh does not allow for task
reordering so we had to put a plugin
that allowed that so I the developer can
say Implement plot should be actually
number one and not number uh three so
they can move this and there is this
little tick mark that says okay run the
constraint solver now so we run the
constant solver two times when the user
says run it now and the other part is
when someone has checked in their code
what we say like the other people who
are still working on I finished my part
what is the next task I should do and it
takes some time for people to checking
their code write the comments and stuff
like that so we use that time to run the
reanalyze the constraint space and
saying you know some constraints will be
added some will be removed based on what
other people are doing what files you
have changed and say this is the next
best task for
you so when we give this visualization
of what's the next best task for you we
kind of say this is the order which we
want you to do and there's a little
exclamation mark that says why we want
you to look at that and over here says
you know this is your task ID it
conflicts with this other person what is
the task that is conflicting it is
direct or indirect conflict that could
be causing this so idea is to kind of
say like it's not just like hey you have
to do task number two but saying if you
do task number two these are some of the
problems you will face and seeing if
developers actually reschedule or do the
same task or they actually pick uh
Cassandra's U uh order what happens if
there is no solution right so this was
the first case when we ran the conent
space we found two tasks that were
independent of each other what if
there's no solution what if an unset
situation
then what that means is we have to relax
some of the constraints we cannot relax
any of the hard constraints because
something has to be done before this
other can be done right the output is
needed for as the input for this task
two so we can relax some of these
software constraints and the way we
relax soft constraint could be very much
dependent on the team policies so you
could have for example a conflict Focus
um initially when we started this we
assumed merge conflicts are easier to
solve so we could just say if there is
no no no solution just uh break all
constraints that cause direct conflicts
right but after looking at the data we
had the milein uh sorry the Pearl data
in Pearl builds is easier to solve than
mergers are right so again it might
depend on the Project's profile what
tasks and what conflicts you want or you
do not want it could be team Focus for
example as I said it might be okay for
two people to have a problem as long as
the majority of the uh Team doesn't have
any conflicts it could be task Focus we
could say these three tasks are going to
the release now so nothing should ever
impact this tasks or it could be these
files are um Frozen because we already
for release or these are a public API so
all constants relating to this
particular file should be left
alone we started with looking at
conflict Focus that was the easiest to
do so what we do is when we have an
unsat model a basic model was start
relaxing by you can do all direct
conflicts or you can do one Conflict at
a time uh Z3 right now does not give a
minimal set it's says okay these are all
the constraints that could happen but it
could be that if you relax one of the
constraint the solution would still work
right so there is some optimization that
we can do right now for starting we said
Okay first step let's relax all the
direct conflicts and see how fast and
how much time it takes um the other one
is empirically guided so you can look at
your particular Project's profile and
see builds are easy so I'm okay with
removing indirect conflicts maybe but in
this case you have to be a little more
uh fine tuned and say remove one
Conflict at a time run the uh constraint
solver and see if you get a solution and
then keep doing
that so there are some of the underlying
assumptions here uh we are assuming
developers select a task from a given
set so there is a set that is awaiting
for them at the beginning of the day or
a week or a month uh there is a task
context that you know we know for this
task these kind of resources are going
to be changed we know that ahead of time
we're doing very Co grain analysis right
now uh that task assignments are done
the beginning of the period so the
weekly time I know these are my task for
this week or particular Sprint uh
there's one active task for developer
it's not that a user has three or four
five tasks all opened because as soon as
you're working on a task we uh
concretize those constraints so we say
this person is working on this nobody
can touch these constraints right um we
also assuming tasks are unique across
developers and non-transferable it's not
that I start something without checking
it in I email it to someone else so
there are two tasks going on at the same
time and another thing isum developers
commit their changes at task completion
and this is kind of important for the
approach is initially when we are
starting there's going to be a lot
of uh noise in the data because we're
kind of looking back in time to find
which files will be changed we're
looking at just call graph analysis so
there's going to be over proximation in
the dependences we have but we're
assuming as developers are making
changes we have much more fine-tuned
idea fine gr idea of what's changing in
the dependencies so when I have
completed my first task then I have a
much better the tool has a much better
idea of the constraint that's out there
to get a much better uh prediction for
the next task you're looking at but if
you don't commit your uh changes then
it's going to be a lot of changes or a
lot of constraints of the space leading
to unset Solutions I'm not going to go
into depth with this because I'm sort of
running out of time so to evaluate it
just to see if Z3 and constant solving
would work in an open source setting we
looked at the four projects we had
Jenkins SPL vort storm we looked at
weekly data monthly quarter and six
months data and and I want to you to
focus on that in many cases we had the
direct and indirect conflicts so 12 34
49 we ran it we saw satad conditions as
well as unsat conditions when we had the
unsat conditions we relax some of the
constraints and if you look at it we got
Solutions there was number of conflicts
that got avoided four out of five 33 out
35 36 out of 40 so we're pretty good in
um resolving this problems of course in
this case we knew exactly what the
change set where and were the
dependencies fa right there was no false
positives involved because this was
gotten data after the fact um okay
conflicts avoided uh another thing is
time was pretty uh this is in seconds it
was pretty fast uh when we looked at it
it was uh 63% developer preferences
match 2325 so we ran it again to see as
close as we got the developers
preference and in this case developers
preference was just based on the order
in which the changes were done and we
saw that most times we got pretty close
to developer preferences matched only in
one case it timed out which was set for
3 minutes so the solution works pretty
fast so to summarize and to conclude
what we have is we have what I have
showed you now is there are dependencies
it's hard to understand what those
dependencies are so here is a set of
tools that actually let you explore
these dependencies through TCT which
looks at different project elements um
Aggregates these different types of
relationships as networks that exist uh
they cross-linking and you can look at
it over time the other set of work that
I talked about is how can we uh schedule
or how can we coordinate the tasks or
different changes that developers are
making in the team context and one thing
is we want to eliminate seclusion so if
you're in a branch if in have private
workspace it's not that you do not know
what's happening around you but we are
insulating it so you have some
information going from early detection
of conflicts to scheduling tasks to
avoid the conflicts altogether and
another thing we have not talked about
is a lot of the stuff that I spoke today
was very Co analysis at the call graph
level but can we use the development
context to do much more uh finer grain
analysis but scope it say for the
behavioral changes for example if you
want to semantic analysis like uh
symbolic execution doing for the entire
code bit is very expensive can we use
the development context like code
ownership or who's active now to scope
this uh analysis space thank you work is
supported by bunch of NSF grants and an
Air Force course Grant um I thank my
students in the lab Josh Cory Baka
sandep and Rafael who did a lot of the
work most of the work which was after I
graduated thank you
questions any time for
questions so in practice with um with
that how are people willing to put in
that upfront work to save like later C
that's something I need to look at as a
user study um so one of the things I
think to help them understand that
that's why we did the past study to say
like how much time it takes for
resolution the resolution time is less
they would not put that upfront time
right um this was a study done by milin
so they were eating their own dog food
and there they found that because uh
what myin would allow is putting the
degree of knowledge information or
degree of Interest information degree of
Interest information that tells you
which other files might be changed
people wanted that information badly
enough that they actually put that extra
time to say I'll be changing this this
this this and this files so in myin it
worked but it was a research group so
this Dem me to be seen how it's going to
work um going back to the palent study
which was less upfront work but the
first time when they saw the conflict
they wanted to just race ahead and
finish it but the next time they found
the problem before they wanted to go
ahead and finish their task they always
started the communication say I'm going
to change these things what are you
changing so people seem to very conflict
a worse in the settings that I had seen
so if if this world help resolve or help
you not even have those conflicts I
believe they should be but it depends
how the development context and team
policies are the cultur the cultural
thing more
questions I can ask one
so in a way the conflict avoidance is
kind of like pessimistic concurrency in
Version Control where if somebody has
that file out and it's locked you can't
check it out you can't touch it um which
brought to mind um the idea of offline
work so one of the challenges um if
you're not connected to your Source
control system um and something's locked
you can't check anything out you can't
do any work until you connect um so this
eliminates essentially parallel
development or the ability for parallel
development um if you're avoiding these
conflicts and so the that was just sort
of an observation um but a question I
had around this was in the studies you
did of um those open source projects the
four that you would put up there how big
were the conflicts were they
multi-person were they more than two
people usually or like if you needed to
coordinate work between to avoid a
conflict was that just
coordinating between two people's tasks
or was it like 15 people needed to have
all their work coordinated there are
open source so they were smaller and the
way we defined the conflict was when two
branches were merged so by definition of
a problem in this case was two people
because there were two branches that
were emerged so it's always two people
but we are looking at kind of Branch
study and at some point in Voldemort we
had 15 branches that were active uh and
I I think there were five or six unique
developers so because it's get everybody
has multiple branches that's going on so
I think the worst case we have seen is
in these projects six people working
simultaneously but the problems that I
have shown is by definition two people
so if you broaden it out and we look at
at this point if all the branches were
to come in there would have been five
people you have to coordinate does it
answer your question it does it has f a
l let
Chris it's kind of separate oh I'll let
you ask your question the follow was so
um you put in a lot of work into the St
system to try to automatically schedule
things if it's potentially just two
people or let's say it's a small number
of people could you get away with just
the visualization of here like a paler
like visualization of here are the tasks
that might overlap with this person or
that person
and if it's not too complex to see maybe
the people can just figure it out for
themselves which on to choose that's
possible so if it is so we are going for
the hardcore case we have 15 20 people
working together but uh if it a smaller
graph of people and relationships we
could just leave it as a visualization
and let them choose the only problem
would be it might become comori
depending on how many tasks each person
has so that's where having some
automated tool would help so Z was
pretty easy you lock it plug it in and
it does match it behind the screen
so so you you've been looking at this
kind of awareness and kind conflict so
you may not have called it like back in
P or whatever
what's what is your feeling about like
uh the type of granularity that that we
people should be looking at when you
talk about conflicts so in one of your
tools you're looking at uh changes to
individual signatures on methods to I've
seen things to files or
components um what are your thoughts on
on how what you think about
or what level of granularity we should
look for these things it's a difficult
question it's a good question right um
sole question the granularity the
granularity of the changes has two
issues one is the human level
scalability of understanding I am
working on this particular file I know
it's going to affect this other file
it's much easier to do than looking at
another team another component but if
you are having a higher granularity of
changes doing doing any kind of impact
analysis gets more complicated with a
lot more possibility of false positives
right so if you're looking at the
component change you have a lot of
changes and it could be this all these
changes have a lot of effects and if
you're over approximating you'll have
everything as being affected it's a
deadlock for no real reason yes you can
have Deadlocks because even if we are
looking at this is even if you look at
um call uh control flow graphs right
most of them get over approximated if
you want to be sound that you want to
catch all the problems then it gets over
approximated everything gets affected so
you have one big lump um if you are
being too tiny then you have an easier
so the smaller the chain sets the easier
it is to understand so one way of
thinking of this I would say depending
on the users's needs so we are talking
it's completely client needs right so if
as a manager I want to say tell me all
the components that are a problem but I
think underlying that we should have for
each of these components these files
these methods this line was changed and
from there do the impact analysis and
aggregate the results back to a form
that users would like to say so for the
technical part the smaller the change
the better it is the lower granularity
for the people part you need some kind
of aggregating and moving things up
otherwise it might just too many
information little difficult and that's
one the reason we moving away from the
paler stuff which was all file based and
we're trying to get to a more higher
level task based
understanding for to address jina's
question about requiring people to put
in a lot of metadata about what each
task might touch could you use some sort
of requirements traceability analysis to
take a task and automatically figure out
what files or functions it's going to be
touching and at least as a first
approximation yes you could I was not
going to requirement traceability I was
looking more data mining part but that
would only work for past bugs so if
there was a bug request then we would
like to find similar past bugs and then
do a seed of these were the files that
change for a very similar bug and then
the user going to refine that but if
it's a new feature then we could do some
kind of requirements traceability part
to say these are the possible files you
might want to do and then they can
refine it so that's the goal I think
starting with a blank slate nobody would
do that but as I think we were having a
discussion if there's a false positive
that you say for this task these five
files need to be changed I think a user
will be more uh apt to say no not this
file but this file so collecting
something might be easier for the user
than working from scratch so that's
something definitely want to look
at more
questions all right well let's thank
Anita for her talk thank
you here till
Friday